JOHN BARRUS: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is John Barrus, and I'll
be talking about Cloud TPUs.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So today I'll be
joined by Jack--
I can't even talk--
Zak Stone, the product manager
at TensorFlow and Cloud TPUs
from the Google Brain team.
So I want to talk a little
bit about machine learning
and Cloud TPUs and
new opportunities
that are available now due
to machine learning, and also
the central computational
challenge related
to machine learning and
what we're doing about it.
So I have a couple of examples
I'd like to mention first.
You know, digital cameras were
created 40 to 45 years ago,
and then about 20 years ago
they became popular even
for consumers.
And if you had a digital
camera 20 years ago,
you might have been taking
pictures, taking the memory
card out of the camera and
sticking it into your computer,
and just saving the
pictures on your hard drive.
And if you wanted to find
a picture from an event
or of a particular person,
you had to kind of either
have good organizational
skills of how
to keep track of photos
on your computer,
or you could remember
when the picture was
taken, kind of search by date
and try to find that photo.
Well, things have
changed a lot nowadays.
I keep my pictures
on Google Photos.
And if I want to
find, for instance,
a picture of the Golden Gate
Bridge or the Eiffel Tower,
I can just type in Golden
Gate Bridge or Eiffel Tower
into the search bar.
And because Google Photos has
used machine learning tools
to identify objects
in those photos,
it can call up all
the pictures that I've
taken of the Golden Gate
Bridge or the Eiffel Tower
and present them
to me so that I can
go through them very quickly.
It's made my life
so much easier.
In fact, if have a friend that
I'd like to find a picture of,
if I've already tagged
that friend in one photo,
I can easily find that friend
and many other photos as well.
So that's super convenient.
So that's an example of
how consumers can save time
using machine learning.
But perhaps you'd be interested
in another example that
is good for enterprises.
And I'm thinking about
automobile manufacturing lines.
It turns out that when an
automobile manufacturing
line goes down, it
costs about $22,000
a minute in lost
revenue, or in costs.
And that's up more than
$1 million an hour.
And so having a machine fail
on that manufacturing line
is actually quite expensive.
And so it's much
better if the company
can identify when the
machine might fail, and then
schedule a maintenance
or repair to that machine
during a time when the line is
down already for maintenance.
And so what a company
might do in that case
is fit those machines with
sensors, maybe audio sensors,
pressure, temperature,
vibration, or anything
like that, and then look at that
data and use machine learning
and use the computers
to identify patterns
in that data that might
indicate when a machine might
be ready for maintenance.
And by doing that, they can
schedule the maintenance
on the machine instead of
having the machine fail
at an inopportune time.
So here's some
other examples, too.
For instance, the Google
Arts and Culture app
that runs on your
phone can use a selfie
and identify a
picture or a drawing
by a famous artist that most
closely matches your selfie.
So our colleague
Sateesh did this here.
And it turns out he
looked most like Chuck
Berry in this drawing
by Gilbert Shelton.
There's another example
that is very useful
when you're traveling.
If you're in a foreign
country and you
can't read the language
that's presented on a street
sign or a menu, you can
actually use the camera
to take a picture of that
menu, and then Google
uses machine learning
to identify the text,
convert that text to a
machine readable format,
convert it into a
language we understand,
and insert that
language in the text
that we can read in the
same place on the image
so that we can read a menu
even in a foreign language.
It's incredibly convenient.
Now here's another example
of making life easier
is Smart Reply in Inbox,
where when a piece of mail
comes in, instead of having
to type with your thumbs
the whole response,
Smart Reply offers
a few responses that might be
appropriate for this message.
And you can just press a
button, and then that response
is inserted into the email.
Then you can add your own
comments and send it off.
It's a nice time saver.
Now it turns out that making
all this machine learning work
effectively and quickly
requires a substantial amount
of computation power
because of the increasing
complexity of machine learning
models that are in use.
So for instance,
image recognition
and object detection models
that are run on images
often have 50 or 100
or even more layers,
and billions of
neurons that can be
activated by the information
coming in to the model.
So in this example, you can see
the input layer at the bottom.
Perhaps that input
layer is taking the data
from the machines that
have been instrumented
in the manufacturing line.
And neurons are activated
based on the input data,
and then that information
activates additional neurons
in layers above that until
finally, the final output
layer might only have two
settings, either Needs
Maintenance Soon or Doesn't
Need Maintenance Soon.
And so that's an example
of how the neurons work
in the machine learning model.
Now what we're finding
is that current solutions
haven't provided enterprises
with enough computing power.
And recent AI advances are
almost all attributable
to advances in compute power.
And in fact, we
surveyed attendees
at a recent TensorFlow event
and found that most of them
felt like their compute
power was inadequate.
They needed much more
computational power.
So our mission at Google
is to democratize AI, make
it available both through
services and infrastructure,
making it accessible, fast,
and useful for enterprises
and developers.
We have over 10,000
customers taking
advantage of our AI solutions.
We've launched 12
products last year
with dozens of
features related to AI.
And we have over 30
Cloud AI partners.
And in fact, we
have over a million
Kaggle members that are
using AI on our platform.
So now, here to tell you more
about Cloud TPUs is Zak Stone.
Zak?
ZAK STONE: Thanks, John.
Hi, everyone.
I'm really excited to talk to
you today about Cloud TPUs.
As you can see here,
this Cloud TPU board
is the latest offering
in Google Cloud,
and it's Google's
second generation
machine learning accelerator.
So as a Product
Manager for TensorFlow,
one thing that John
mentioned earlier
is that most
TensorFlow users who
are working with state of
the art deep neural networks
are hungry for more compute.
In TensorFlow it's
open source, it's free,
it runs across a huge variety
of different platforms
from state of the art
CPUs to GPUs to Cloud TPUs
and onto mobile and
embedded devices.
So across all those
devices, we're
committed to
TensorFlow providing
fantastic performance.
Today we're focusing on this
Cloud TPU, this new addition
to the lineup in Google Cloud.
So what's special about
this second generation TPU?
Well, first of all,
on the reference
workloads that
we've open-sourced,
this provides differentiated
performance per dollar.
We think this is a
really economical way
to get work done, especially
on some of these incredibly
intense computational
challenges associated
with state of the art
machine learning systems.
Each board delivers
up to 180 teraflops
per device, which is
a lot if you've ever
built a system yourself.
And by hosting
these in Cloud, you
can scale up and scale down
easily as your needs change,
instead of having to put in the
capital and expertise and data
center cooling and
power and so forth
to build a cluster like
this and manage it yourself.
Right now these Cloud TPUs are
architected for TensorFlow,
so you can program them with
TensorFlow's high level APIs
instead of having to do
bespoke supercomputer
programming as you might
have in a previous era.
Let me tell you
a little bit more
about the motivation
behind these Cloud TPUs.
First of all, it's
really important
to be able to train and run
complex machine learning models
faster.
As John mentioned,
one of the trends
that we've observed over
the past several decades,
really, but especially
over the past five years
is that increasing computational
power and scale of these models
has led to much higher
accuracy and unlocked
new applications that just
wouldn't have been feasible
previously.
Also, we find that it's
really important here
at Google, and elsewhere
across the world,
to improve the productivity
of machine learning teams.
When you are training a
machine learning model,
it's common to wait
for hours or days,
or even, in some cases,
weeks for the model
to converge and be ready
to deploy in production.
That's like waiting weeks
for your code to compile.
And so what we're trying
to do, both with TensorFlow
across all platforms and
then with Cloud TPUs,
is to reduce that time to hours,
and perhaps some day to minutes
so people can iterate faster
and be more productive.
Finally, as I
mentioned earlier, it's
really valuable to be able
to scale up and down easily
with on-demand machine learning
infrastructure in the Cloud.
You don't have to
fight with provisioning
machines, configuring drivers.
You can just connect to your
virtual machine to a Cloud TPU,
start running open
source TensorFlow,
and train faster
than ever before.
Let me say a little
bit more about ML
teams of ML engineers, ML
researchers, data scientists.
One thing that you're
probably aware,
as we certainly are
here, is that the talent
to build these state of the
art machine learning models
is in very high demand
right now and very scarce.
And so it's really
important for the people
that you have in
your organization who
have the strongest
expertise in this domain
to be able to move as
quickly as possible.
And so with these
higher performance
accelerators and great, high
level software on top of them,
you can enable your teams to
accomplish a lot more than they
could otherwise.
Furthermore, I'd
like to emphasize,
as I mentioned before,
that this is now
the second in a whole line of
machine learning accelerators
that Google has
developed in-house.
We had our first generation
tensor processing
unit that was optimized for
inference and used internally.
This is the second
generation tensor processing
unit built into a
Cloud TPU board,
and even into larger systems
that I'll tell you about in
a minute.
So every time you run a
search, your search results
are ranked in conjunction with
some of these tensor processing
units here at Google.
When you use Google Photos,
as John mentioned earlier,
some of the organization
of those photos
is facilitated with these
tensor processing units.
And across many other
Google products,
you're interacting with
these accelerators every day.
And now you have the
opportunity to incorporate
the same accelerators
into your own businesses
through Google Cloud.
One thing that
we're trying to do
is to make it easy for people
to get started with Cloud TPUs.
And the way that
we're approaching that
is by open sourcing
reference workloads
that are optimized and ready
to go on these Cloud TPUs.
Initially we have concentrated
on a few categories
of reference workloads, on
visual recognition, so image
classification.
These are models like
ResNet-50 or Inception,
or for lower resource devices,
MobileNet and SqueezeNet.
And this is really useful if
you have an object centered
in a frame, you know
where you're looking,
and you need to tell is
this a cat or is it a dog?
Is this a vehicle in this
close crop of an image,
or is it pavement for an
autonomous driving application?
So we have a lot of models
there that are ready to go,
well-optimized, and
we're continuing
to improve their performance
further over time.
Secondly, we've got
reference models
in machine translation
and language modeling.
These are built around the
state of the art transformer
model that's part of the
open-source Tensor2Tensor
library.
And Transformer has been
really useful for both machine
translation from one
language to another, also
for language
modeling, where you're
trying to predict the
next word in a sentence,
as you might if you're
building a messaging app
and you want to make it easier
for people to input messages
to one another.
But Transformer is
actually more general
and useful for other
sequence-to-sequence problems
as well.
Finally, related to the small
image visual classification
I mentioned earlier, we've
got a reference model
for object detection
called RetinaNet.
So this is useful if you
don't have a small crop,
but instead you're
searching for small objects
in a large field
of view, like you
might for autonomous driving,
but also for medical imaging.
You might need to look
for regions of an image
that a medical practitioner
should focus on
in a large scan that
may be many megapixels.
And so RetinaNet might be
a useful starting point
if you're interested in
those sorts of applications.
Just to give you a
sense of how broad
the application domains are,
even with these building
blocks of these
reference workloads
that I mentioned earlier,
I'd like to call out
a few other applications.
One that's quite surprising
is genetic variant calling.
So when you're
sequencing a genome,
there's this final
step when you're
reconstructing
the sequence where
you need to call variants.
You need to decide,
OK, the reads
are suggesting that there's
a base pair modified here.
Is that base pair
really modified or not?
Is this a real variant or not?
And so a team here at
Google has developed
an algorithm called Deep Variant
that recasts this problem that
traditionally takes hours
or days on a cluster of CPUs
as an image recognition
problem that you can now
run on these state of the art
machine learning accelerators,
whether GPUs or TPUs.
And so this dramatically
speeds up the process,
and we think this will make
genetic sequencing faster
and a lot more affordable
to be used in many new ways.
As I mentioned before,
autonomous vehicles
are a really important
domain for visual recognition
and object detection.
And there are many
aspects to that problem.
There's some teams
that are considering
running machine
perception on vehicles,
detecting pedestrians and
street signs and road markings
and obstacles and so forth.
Those are all visual
perception problems.
But also visual
recognition and processing
is valuable for the mapping
that often goes on beforehand.
Before the vehicles
even go out on the road,
you need to understand
the world in great detail
so they have an accurate map
of where they can drive and not
drive.
And finally, obviously,
there's a huge amount
of opportunity in retail.
Retailers everywhere
are experimenting
with new kinds of customer
experiences, checkout
experiences, in-store
experiences, shopping
experiences online.
And all of these experiences
tend to be highly visual
and require detailed
understanding of what's
present in an image, in a
scene, in a live video stream.
And so we think these state of
the art Cloud TPUs are going
to be helpful for
rapid prototyping
and then deployment of these
new retail experiences.
So I mentioned earlier that
these Cloud TPUs on the left
are the ones that are available
today in beta and Google Cloud.
But they're also designed
to be connected together
into even larger
systems like the TPU pod
that you can see
over on the right.
Now these pods are amazing.
This has a total of 256 of
these TPU chips, 64 boards,
and can deliver up to 11 and
1/2 petaflops of computing
performance for a single
machine learning problem,
if you want to train a
model in half an hour
instead of in days.
And these are coming to
Cloud later this year.
We think these
Cloud TPU pods are
going to provide a
great solution for folks
who are starting their
development now on Cloud TPUs
with no code changes
to then scale up
by more than an
order of magnitude
without any code changes, as
long as you can tolerate larger
batch sizes.
So one thing that we've
announced recently
is that our own
internal experiments
have shown that you
can take a model that
would train in
about a day on one
of these boards in a
certain configuration,
and scale that all the
way down to 30 minutes
training on a Cloud TPU pod.
And we're continuing to
optimize these systems further.
So we're looking forward to
bringing these to Google Cloud
so you can enjoy them as well.
So if you want to get started,
since the demand is intense,
we ask that you
visit the page here,
cloud.google.com/tpu
and request quota.
And we're doing our best to
process those quota requests
as quickly as we can.
Thank you very much.
We'll be taking questions
in just a moment.
We'll be right back
after a minute break.
Thanks again.
JOHN BARRUS: Welcome back.
We have a few questions
we'd like to answer.
So we'll mention the
question and give the answer.
First of all, someone said,
I've applied for TPU quota
during alpha and again at beta,
and I haven't heard anything.
When will I get a chance
to try Cloud TPUs?
Well, I have to say,
they've been very popular.
We just ask for your patience.
You'll get a chance soon.
But thanks for your
patience and waiting.
ZAK STONE: Totally.
Again, we wish we
could give these
to everyone right now, so
we're trying as hard as we can.
There's a second question here.
I saw an article indicating
the cost of training on TPUs
is much more expensive
compared to NVIDIA Volta GPUs.
So while we won't make
direct comparisons today,
one thing that
we'd encourage you,
when you get access
to Cloud TPUs,
is to run benchmarks yourself
on your own workloads.
It's actually really subtle
to run a benchmark accurately.
You need to decide are
you processing real data
and measuring the full
performance of your input
pipeline?
Are you running
on synthetic data?
Are you testing that the
model converges all the way
to the right accuracy, as we do
with our reference workloads?
Or are you just looking at
the step time performance?
We're pretty confident
that we offer
differentiated performance
per dollar for our reference
workloads.
And we're already starting to
see some of our early users
running their own benchmarks
and talking about them online.
So the performance
will definitely
be different from one
workload to another.
And it's really
important for you
to run your own
experiments to decide
what accelerator works for you.
The important thing to recognize
is that Google Cloud's goal
is to offer the best
experience for machine
learning across all workloads.
And that means we're hosting
the state of the art CPUS,
state of the art GPUs, and
state of the art Cloud TPUs.
So we don't want this to be an
either/or or kind of a thing.
You should be able to test on
all of the state of the art
machine learning platforms,
and on a workload
by workload basis,
figure out which ones
are most appropriate for you.
JOHN BARRUS: The next question
is, can I use PyTorch, Caffe,
or other frameworks
for programming
So today we offer
TensorFlow for program TPUs.
So that's the only thing
that's available right now.
We've heard people
request PyTorch and Caffe.
We don't have a
solution for you today,
but I'd say stay in tune, and
if we have anything to offer,
we'll let you know.
But today it's TensorFlow only.
ZAK STONE: Great.
There's a question
here, can I do inference
on TPUs or only training?
So that's a great question.
So TPUs support
training and inference.
At the moment, in
beta, the best support
is, we spend a lot of
time optimizing training.
We've also got some early
support for batch inference.
If you have some huge
corpus of images, let's say,
that you need to process with a
trained model, that's something
you can do today.
We are working on more
optimizations over time
to support low
latency inference,
but we wouldn't recommend
that right now in production.
JOHN BARRUS: The
next question is,
this is a second generation of
TPU, as Zak mentioned earlier.
Will there be a
third generation,
and can you tell us
anything about it?
Well, Google Cloud has
not announced anything
about future
generations of TPUs.
So we don't have anything
to say about that right now.
ZAK STONE: All I can comment
is that broadly speaking,
hardware architecture
is interesting again.
So there's a whole variety
of new hardware platforms
that are becoming available
both here and elsewhere.
Let's see if we have
any other questions.
JOHN BARRUS: We don't
have any other questions.
So stay tuned for
the next session.
Showcase your data stories
online with Google Data Studio.
ZAK STONE: Thanks
for checking in.
We appreciate it.